nous avons suivi un préfet en première
ligne face au terrorisme c sur le reste
héros qu'on accorde un aveu
à lui a gagné ses galons de hauts
fonctionnaires au mérite
d'autre part la seule volonté du pouvoir
obtienne les meilleurs places sans
passer le moindre concours on sommes
plutôt des gens qu'on connaît plutôt que
des gens comme ce n'est pas ça c'est
clair
des amis parfois incompétents
remercié par un job à vie avec à la clé
retraite garantie et gros salaires
quinze mille euros c'est énorme ou 12500
euros c'est énorme pour quelqu'un qui ne
remplit pas son ces fonctions là bas
enquête sur les bons et les mauvais
élèves de la république mérite et
compétences sont ils les seuls critères
pour accéder aux plus hautes fonctions
publiques
nous avons découvert que certains
empruntent une porte dérobée
ici à l'elysée ils n'ont pas passé de
concours n'ont pas gravi les échelons de
l'administration
ils sont nommés directement par le
président de la république de la
république cela se passe tous les
mercredis à la fin du conseil des
ministres un temps est consacré aux
nominations dans la haute fonction
publique
[Musique]
à la sortie nous retrouvons patrick
kanner le ministre de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur k vers
monsieur camara bonjour quelles ont été
les nominations aujourd'hui de hauts
fonctionnaires
elles vont être publiés à l'acheter
annoncé en temps il ya eu plusieurs et
plusieurs montmaur de préfet
effectivement dans le compte rendu du
jour
on voit par exemple qu'un ingénieur a
été nommé à la cour des comptes et une
administratrice civile est devenu
préfète mais qui tire les ficelles de
ces nominations
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
claude guéant était secrétaire général
de l'elysée il nous révèle que les
nominations se décident des deux jours
avant le conseil des ministres
c'était une rencontre tous les lundis à
déjeuner à l'elysée
dans la salle à manger d'un permanence
entre le directeur de cabinet du premier
ministre et puis d'euskal terral de
l'e10 est de 3 collaborateurs et ce jour
là sous réserve bien sûr de
l'approbation finale du premier ministre
du président de la république sont
décidés de telles nominations
je n'ai jamais vu ni entendu la moindre
remarque de la part d'un membre du
gouvernement
les nominations concernent tous les
grands corps de la haute fonction
publique cour des comptes conseil d'état
l'inspection générale des finances ou de
l'éducation nationale 20% des hauts
fonctionnaires sont nommés par les
politiques
rien de choquant pour annick girardin
ministre de la fonction publique
le principe de ces nominations par
l'elysée servirait à diversifier les
profils des hauts fonctionnaires
le galon de préfets sont un joli cadeau
le job est garanti à vie
le salaire va de six à douze mille euros
nets par mois et la retraite minimum est
de 4000 euros nets selon claude guéant
certaines nominations servent de
parachutes dorés aux amis politiques
c'est sûr que il ya 102 personnes qui
trouvent dans ces nominations le moyen
de donner une certaine stabilité à leur
devenir personnel et encore une fois on
sommes plutôt des gens que l'on connaît
plutôt que des gens comme prenez pas ça
c'est clair
depuis les années 80 tous les
gouvernements ont élevé des amis au
grade de préfet du jour au lendemain
françois mitterrand en sommes une
soixantaine
parmi eux michel vauzelle son
porte-parole à l'elysée où michel
delbarre l'un de ses anciens ministres
[Musique]
jacques chirac promeut jean charles
marchiani ex agent secret et homme de
l'ombre de la chiraquie alors que
nicolas sarkozy ministre du budget puis
de l'intérieur son fidèle lieutenant
brice hortefeux 37 ans ainsi que son
chef de cabinet
laurent solly 36 ans sont nommés préfets
le gouvernement de françois hollande a
lui aussi récompensé ses proches
collaborateurs pierre besnard chef de
cabinet du président et yves colmou
conseiller de manuel valls
sébastien gros 34 ans chef de cabinet de
manuel valls et christian gravel 41 ans
chef du service de l'information du
gouvernement
tous ont été propulsés préfet sur un
effectif de 250 préfet seulement 127
étaient affectés à un poste territorial
reste 123 préfet sans préfecture on les
appelle les préfets organes sains la
haute fonction publique sert donc
parfois recaser les proches du pouvoir
en leur assurant un emploi à vie
le système n'épargne pas les
administrations les plus prestigieuses